hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
from Monday
Monday April 17 2023
what's going on how are ya how's it
going with you
um
I just got back from College Station in
Austin Texas and I could not
have had a bit I had such a good [__]
time I think I'm gonna go sit over in my
[__] chair
instead of this chair that I'm sitting
in
if I can figure out how to get these
wires
the goddamn wires to not be crossed over
here
um I had a great [__] time and this
is just wasting your time by talking
about what a great time I had as I moved
[__] over why wouldn't I do this to
begin with is my to go to my headphones
are they long enough
will this work can this happen can I
live the dream can I sit in a chair and
do a podcast and I can
it happened everybody
um
all right first things first thank you
to everybody
that came out to uh
you Tate not ut oh my God not UT that's
University Texas University of Texas A M
Texas A M agricultural thank you for
everybody that came out arguably
like
one of one of the coolest crowds I've
been in front of
in a long time they just were fun
everybody came out to have a good time I
went out I was with Dean Del Rey
we went up there and uh
I don't even know what the [__] I talked
to I riffed it was so much fun I think I
winged like the first 25 minutes of my
set just [__] around
making fun of [__] making fun of them
making fun of myself and um
it all uh it all worked out it all
worked out they were fun people
something the crowd gave me [__] about
owning a Prius back in the day we got
back we got into that then I was telling
them that you know I'm kind of like you
guys you know and that I'm also buying a
big big Ford truck that's never going to
go off-road and I don't really fix
anything and I don't have a ranch
you know
I spend most of my time on YouTube
um the sound was amazing the people
there were amazing seriously that um
that College Station gig was one of my
favorite gigs I've done in a long long
time and uh
why why were we out there
by the way we played uh
the place where the uh uh the Aggies
basketball team plays
right
and uh [__] place was huge it was an
amazing Arena and someone was telling me
that they they said they need a they
need a new one
it's unreal just the environmental
[__] disaster it's like why do you
need a new one it used to be
oh oh Billy old shoes here it used to be
they they would make an arena
and they would hold on to the arena so
[__] long that everybody who played
on the first team
you know in the first game ever on both
sides everyone was dead everyone in the
crowd was dead and then they'd finally
be like all right we need to build a new
[__] Arena
right like the Boston Garden they kept
that for 60 something years even that
seems quick
but that should be a rule because now
it's like that they're making these
arenas
and they go for about 30 years and
they're just like yeah we need a new one
yeah
something sexier
we have to cater to all the people that
don't really give a [__] about a game
you know or the younger crowd we got to
make sure we got all the [__] bells
and whistles
and all of that [__]
I don't know I watched the Bruins
against the Canadiens
speaking of which their first playoff
game tonight against the Florida
Panthers and we'll see we'll see what
happens
historically speaking uh
setting a regular season record
for wins or points does not mean you win
the cup the last two times it did not
happen
by the way some [__] grouchy old
Canadians fan was like Ty shouldn't
count
Ty shouldn't count
the 1977 Montreal Canadiens are the
greatest team that every year you can
get it's like well what if Ty's counted
back then they don't count now you'd
still be saying
that the 77 Canadians were the greatest
team because you're a [__] Canadians
fan
you know
it's like congratulations yes you
dominated a six Team league that had
then expanded to 12. the expansion six
were [__]
you know
I don't know 10 years old
if 12 13 teams in the [__] League 15
a couple of WHL teams go [__] yourself
you [__] set a record 50 goddamn
years ago
you know also did great 1977 the [__]
Bee Gees
should be dancing
I mean we're talking back then
I Love The Nightlife I got to a boogie
on the Disco
oh yeah that was like play during your
Championship parade
why
why not ironically
not ironically that was actually a hit
Macho macho man
if you want my body and you think I'm
sexy come on sugar let me know please
welcome
your
1976-77 Montreal Canadiens
everybody on the team look like those
old pictures and old barber shops where
they show [__] haircuts
foreign
anyway but what I did love about it
was everything great about the Montreal
Canadiens is at least 30 years old
at this point
30 years old go back to Patrick was
first [__]
Championship now you're going back 37
years
you know and then you go back to the
late 70s you're 40 plus years
you're almost going back half a century
you know it was great uh this Canadians
team that played no not in this Arena it
was the one before that
um anyway so I wasn't even talking [__]
I just said congratulations to the
Bruins on an amazing regular season and
then some Canadians fan
blue Blanco Rouge [__]
had to write oh can we um it's like I
don't give a [__] right with your
straight sticks and you know [__]
helmets
I think they had curb sticks back then
but like most the guys in your team
weren't wearing helmets all right why
don't you take that [__] record
all right uh make a paper airplane out
of it I'm trying to do it like
technology from back then
all right why don't you sit down at a
typewriter
and type out why you think don't send me
a [__] email
I want you to use the technology from
back then take out a feather
and write on a [__] scroll and tell
me why that that's the greatest [__]
that's not the greatest [__] team
ever
Jesus Christ
they got absolutely [__] smoked
in 1980
by what I think is the greatest [__]
hockey team all of all time is those
still Wayne Gretzky still there Edmonton
Oilers you take the best Edmonton Oiler
team whatever one you want what you want
to say 84 87
right 85 whatever [__] team you want
to pick
all right we'll say 85
84.85 somewhere around there they would
[__] smoke the 77 Canadians I didn't
hear anybody from Edmonton chirping
you know
those Oil Barons up there looking down
at the people in Calgary
with their cattle and their [__]
cowboy hats
um anyway I did really just [__]
steered me off did the Canadians make
the playoffs this year I don't even know
um
are they waiting for that goaltender to
get healthy again
sorry
anyway what is funny is every Canadians
fan that I know
actually hate for some [__] up reason
seems to hate the Toronto Maple Leafs
more than the Bruins
it's weird because they always say the
Bruins Canadians
like rivalry is uh is the biggest
rivalry in hockey or whatever the [__]
they are one of the big rivalries in
sport and they just don't I think it's
because those are American shows
like I got I got a buddy of mine he's a
Canadians fan
and he told me he's you know goes good
luck in the playoffs I hope you guys do
all right I go you don't mean that we're
the Bruins he goes honestly I don't give
a [__] he goes as long as the Leafs
don't win it
and I'm like dude the Leafs haven't won
it
I'm gonna be 55. they haven't won it
since a year before they won it in 56
[__] years
you got twice as many cups as they do
like what what the [__] do you care
you know
you know what it is I just think that
they're in each other's worlds
I wonder how that all went went South
you know two beautiful cities a bunch of
great people
oh yeah I don't [__] I don't know
anyway
so I go to College Station
I go up there I do my set Dean Del Rey
kills I killed the crowd was [__]
amazing like I said
um had a great time talking about trucks
and guns [__] feeding animals and
acting like they all didn't have the
internet
and they knew that that's what I was
doing and they just kind of they went
along with it
um
and then I just talked about you know
being from you know
Hollywood
and you know underage women in our hot
tubs and all that [__] and they [__]
they love it as long as you [__] on
everybody it all works out except every
once in a while somebody gets up [__]
they get all upset they get their
[__] panties in a bunch
yeah I've had to deal with that [__]
lately people getting their [__]
panties in a bunch
[__] bunch of babies
um anyway so the reason I I booked that
gig there
was because I wanted to go to the Moto
GP race race number three of 2023.
and I wanted to I wanted to finally
check out this sport live that I've been
such a huge fan of
and so we went there Saturday Dean Del
Rey knew some people at Ducati Dean Dean
[__] know somebody
I swear to God if you go to Kazakhstan
he would [__] know somebody out there
like the guy just knows people so I go
dude I'm gonna get tickets he goes he
goes don't worry but that's like a
couple months back he goes all right
dude I know the CEO of Ducati I've been
riding motorcycles for 30 years I didn't
[__] know everybody I'll I'll get us
in there he totally hooks us up
um
we got to go down into the paddock
and all of these guys that I see on TV
you know
I mean I want to [__] up their names all
those Italian Guys Gigi all of those
guys
I met all of them we got to go into
where they were working on the bikes
you know Pekka's bike is sitting right
there
and uh uh what's his face uh
Bastian anini however you say his last
name the number one bike the number 23
bike
[__] Ducati sitting right there
and we were behind like a politician and
we just watched him work on it and we
were so geeking out
that the guy actually let us come around
into the area where they were working
because we just wouldn't shut up asking
them [__] questions
about those buttons on the on the left
side and all that he just cycled through
all of it like the different tractions
and all of that and was explaining how
they're going the straightaway and the
bike will just like you push the button
and then the back end goes down low and
they just [__] open the throttle up
you know the day of the race we saw it
and like the front tire is not on the
surface
like almost for like three quarters of
the straightaway it looked like but um
they could not have been nicer
um
and then what did we do we just walked
around the track we took pictures on the
track and then they had this thing you
know Dean was saying it goes hey you
know they do this thing for like fans
where you can do a lap around the track
on a Ducati I go get the [__] out of
here he goes yeah man he goes I'm gonna
do it and I was like ah [__] I haven't
ridden in 11 years you know
let me know how that is he goes dude you
can do it
you could do it
I don't know man like I've probably I
don't even think I've ridden a
motorcycle 30 times in my lifetime I
don't know how to do it you can do I'm
like all right I'll do it right
so I thought it was going to be like 10
or 15 [__] people
dude I show up it was like a parade
like we won a war it looked like there
was a hundred people
wasn't that many it was probably like 50
[__] people on motorcycles and
everybody is like a motorcycle person
they showed up with their own bikes they
had all the [__] gear and here comes
all [__] weepy Willy right I come in
there
and I was just like all right dude I
want to ride in the back let you guys
all go nuts I'll be back here right in
half a mile an hour and
um
one of the guys that gave me the heads
up because you actually don't want to be
in the back you actually want it's safer
up front you follow like a pickup truck
that sort of the pace car slash truck
around the track he goes you want to be
up front he goes people like kind of
want to be in the back so they can lay
back and run through the gears and he
goes you know you might get hit
foreign
I'm like all right
okay all right whatever all right [__]
it I'm doing it all right so I'm putting
on all the [__]
and they go you want to get used to the
bike uh
I'm like yeah I would like to me you
know let the clutch out a couple of
times so I can kind of not stall
with [__] you know 50 amped up moms
and dads behind me that just want to
[__] show why they should be Racing
moto GP you know
so um
they get me on the bike
and you know I'm doing it
and like you know I'm walking it I'm
getting it going and
I was just sort of laughing at myself
like going like how the [__] do I get
myself involved in this [__] like my
life is literally
it's just one never-ending me getting
ready to do something I have no business
doing that really is my [__] life so
much of this [__]
since I started doing stand-up
you know especially in comedy going like
Jesus Christ there's no stage there's no
microphone what the father hey welcome
Bill Billy Byrne I'd [__] walk out
there and get humiliated just constantly
this [__] right so
we're waiting to go out on the track and
I'm like all right as long once I get
this [__] thing going I'll be fine
and the guy says all right just let you
know in the end we stop on the the the
line that ends the pits and
at the uh
Circuit of the Americas or Coda as they
call it that's on a steep incline like
the the
start Finish Line is a straightaway that
then goes uphill and it turns into turn
one
so I'm sitting there going like dude I
don't want to stop on that Hill because
I'm gonna have to use the back brake I
don't know how to [__] it I haven't done
that forever the guy said don't worry
we'll stop we'll stop further so I say
okay good
he goes we'll do do the group photo more
towards at the top of the hill we say
okay cool
so anyway we finally get out there
uh I let out the clutch it's going I'm
walking it I get it going and I'm out on
the track and I swear to God it all came
back to me what little I knew
you know shifted into second gear when
you know what the hell [__] went
around the hill stayed in second gear
don't [__] tip over
you know then you go into [__] uh
turn three four five a little S turn and
I'm like oh [__] I remember how to do
this
I start going a little faster
first of all I'm getting [__] passed
like you can't I thought people gonna
respect sodium it wasn't it was sort of
a free-for-all people were having fun
and these people all knew how to ride
and I didn't so I just made sure I
stayed over to the side
um
but I had a good time went into like
turn
he's going to like have to turn 10 it's
downhill I downshifted I'm like all
right still man but I do that bike was
really forgiving it was a Ducati Diavel
um absolutely loved the bike
uh and we ended up going around by the
time I got to like the back stretch
which is the fastest part of the track I
was doing like [__] you know 60 miles
an hour which is you know it's fast for
me
and uh
I was like I'm gonna buy this bike
and there was something I had gone you
have a wife and two kids I was like I
don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] I I am I am totally
right now in this moment I'm gonna buy
this [__] bike right
going to turn 12 and then all these
crazy turns all the way through like
turn 18 and then 19
and then 20 and then you're back on the
straightaway and everybody was like wow
everybody flew down that's when I got it
up to 60. actually Oh Billy went up to
third gear oh couldn't believe it and it
was such a stable bike like the back
tire was as fat as my [__] head
and then we're going ready for the group
picture I'm like oh good he's gonna stop
at the top of the hill I did it I don't
have nothing to worry about no
didn't didn't communicate it to the
truck they stopped you know three
quarters of the way up the hill and now
I'm stopped there
and everybody's trying to like be like
in the first row it was like three rows
of people all the way across the track I
got the picture and I'm all the way over
to the right with one other person to
the right and I got the back brake on
and I'm going like ah Jesus Christ all
right so
you know give it some throttle as you e
e ease off the clutch let off the back
brake at the same [__] time I'm
trying to practice doing it and the
longer they're making us wait
to go because we're gonna go around the
track again the more these people were
getting amped up and they'd already done
the you know ridden the track once so
they're behind me like yeah
I'm sitting there like hey man like I
just came out here to be in first gear
man like I was and I was just laughing
going right worst case in it well worst
case scenario somebody [__]
rear-ends me but like
um they finally take the [__] picture
and then we go off again and uh I didn't
stall it it was not pretty I definitely
did the oh I had to walk it a little bit
in the [__] front tire left right
left right then I got going and I was
like oh thank God I didn't do that and
then I I was even thinking like okay I
can ride the second lap faster
you know typical [__] that's what
I'm thinking but fortunately we only
went through like uh turn one and two
and then there was another pickup Block
in the track to take us
in
to go back underneath the track and
bring it back and at that point I was
like holy [__]
I somehow did this I was so convinced I
was going to stall the bike or I was
gonna somehow wipe out or something and
I didn't and after basically going
around the track once and doing Turn one
and two twice
having not had anything bad happen my
ego was literally like oh I could ride
the 405 in this thing no [__] problem
like that's that's how much of a rush it
was I know that's not true and I'm not
going to do that all right
foreign
so I don't do that
um I absolutely love that bike and I
always you know
for the last 11 years my big regret when
I stopped riding motorcycles
was that I never got to write a Ducati
and I talked to uh
um Dave Chappelle one time and he goes
do you ever read a Ducati when I'm still
writing I kind of stuck with the Harleys
and he was like oh man he goes you ride
a Ducati you'll never go back and that
always stuck with me and I was like what
the [__] is with the Ducati I gotta know
and and I never did it and whenever I
would do Largo when you go drive down La
Cienega
there's this Ducati dealership and I
always every [__] time
I wouldn't even be thinking I was like
muscle memory my head would turn to the
left
and I would look and I would think yep
there's those beautiful red bikes I'm
never gonna [__] ride
and uh who knew I'd finally get to ride
one and I'd get to do it there and I get
to go see uh
the Moto GP race so let's get to that
first of all thank you to everybody at
Ducati like that was literally
I mean I'm gonna think about riding that
bike around that track on my deathbed
you know that's going to be one of the
things that comes around like as sad as
I'll be that my life is over and the fun
is going to end I'm gonna be like you
know what I had a great life
beautiful wife two beautiful kids I got
to tell jokes for a living and I got to
write a Ducati
Diavel around
a Moto GP official [__] race track
and uh I mean it was just it was on I
can't I can't thank any anybody who was
involved in somehow getting me to do it
from Dean to everybody Ducati it was
[__] unbelievable and I did not come
down
off of that high
yet I still haven't I still haven't like
we me and Dean you know
shared a car back from LAX
and I just looked at him I go dude we
rode ducati's
around the circuit what the [__] I can't
forget what they call it people are
saying Coda because I'm a Led Zeppelin
fan
Kota c-o-t-a Circuit of the Americas
track
um
it was Unreal and then they had like
they had a Sprint race on Saturday which
I didn't know that they they did they do
it so they'll attract more fans on
Saturday and it actually counts for like
half points and
um I want to say pekko won that one
Becca won that one uh
and then it was like it was such an
amazing day Saturday I was actually
worried that the races weren't going to
live up
to
um riding a bike around the [__]
track so
it gets better that night
um
I text everyone we drive back you know
we're back in Austin and I text everyone
over at Joe Rogan's new club The Comedy
Mothership I was going over there to
[__] check that place out which I
already saw like most of you I saw the
videos
on the internet I was like my God this
place looks amazing and I went in there
and uh I'm not I'm not even like
I'm not gonna even just mince words here
that's the greatest Comedy Club I've
ever [__] been in and I've been in
some [__] great ones
you know Caroline's these are the best
ones I was in before Joe's Caroline's
hilarities in Cleveland
uh Comics the one that when it was in
the Meatpacking District went out of
business Gotham
uh uh uh the stand
those who are like like so nice you're
like how is this still a comedy club
because you're used to him being like
smaller holes in the wall or whatever
you know
and I went to the Rogan one and
I don't even know where to begin all I
can tell is when you go in that place
you can tell that every [__] thing on
the wall on the floor on the ceiling
sight lines everything in that place
was painstakingly gone over
to make sure that it was absolutely
perfect and that's what I kept telling
Joe he goes how do you like the club and
I was like dude it is [__]
perfect
it's [__] perfect
um
you have to like the colors of the boot
the uh the mitzi's place I think that's
what it's called the bar downstairs
um the main room the smaller room I only
did I did two I did set Saturday and
Sunday there in the smaller room and I
love that place and uh Harlan Williams
what do you say there freckles he was
there in the main room so I got to see
him
um
headline that place and uh
yeah just
The Green Room
the food
the whole thing
was amazing and I knew that he would
have this option I was like if a
comedian is designing the club he's
going to have the option that you can
either
deal with the crowd or not deal with the
crowd meaning when your set is over if
you want to go out and talk to the crowd
AKA you had a good set
[Laughter]
or maybe maybe you didn't maybe you
pissed a few people off and when you go
behind the curtain you just want to stay
there and you can get to the Green Room
without having to deal with anybody it
is [__] amazing but the coolest thing
that combined
um
two huge worlds of mine stand-up comedy
and Stevie Ray Vaughan
Stevie Ray Vaughan I guess played that
place when it was it was called The Ritz
back in the day and uh well that's
another thing it was it was a like a
punk
club and he had for wallpaper in the
green room all like
the actual posters of all of these
punk bands you know Circle Jerks Misfits
all of these classic bands I'm not a big
punk band guy I'm not cool I was
listening to Disco
[Music]
as you heard when I was making fun of uh
I was making fun of the Canadians
um but Stevie Ray Vaughan played there
in like 1983 and Joe somehow got
somebody to find photos of him playing
there and for big Stevie Ray Vaughan
fans it was that time in his career
right before he started wearing a cowboy
hat on stage and he had that that sort
of that Kang that Kango style I don't
want to call it like the Brian Johnson
style hat
that he had when you know right from
when he was Stevie Ray Vaughan and
triple threat and he had a woman in the
band before he got with Chris Layton
Tommy Shannon double trouble before they
added Reese yeah
I'm kind of into those guys
um anyway he had these two amazing
like life-size Photos of Stevie Ray
Vaughan and Stevie Ray Vaughan is like
one of those artists that I find
transcends what he does like he's so
good at what he does even though you
don't like you know I tell jokes I don't
play guitar he's so [__] good at it
it's like
like I want to get better at what I like
how do you become how do I become the
Stevie Ray Vaughan of what I'm doing
which obviously is impossible I mean
that guy's that guy's a once in a
century talent but it makes but it does
make you dig deeper and try to get
better so to see those those pictures
and also just to know that you're in a
place
that that that guy played in like I
really feel that when you perform in a
place like that like whatever they did
the magic of it is somewhere there if
you're into that spiritual [__] which I
actually am
um so
I went down there that night Joe wasn't
there so I had to see him so I made sure
the next night I went down there again
to hang out with them
um
but uh you know Adam Ray was down there
to one of my favorites and I I met a
couple of comedians there
this guy William that was hosting I
never got his last name he was funny as
hell and then I brought this kid up that
I thought was great uh named Miles
Johnson was really funny just really you
know and the club also had open mic
night
which is something that went away during
my stand-up career it was how an open
mic night was crucial
for new Comedians and it was crucial for
the comedy clubs
to keep you know it was like the draft
you know you had to keep developing new
new uh new comedians to keep the scene
alive
and
um I always felt that one of the big
mistakes that so many comedy clubs did
was they stopped having Open Mic nights
and then it just became like
like the Dust Bowl where you just keep
farming on the same land until it's just
you know nothing grows there anymore you
know so
um
that was another great thing and it's
right on 6th Street and it's just you
know
um I mean I was sixth Street's a little
loud for me in my old ears but like it
is you feel like that excitement of of
Youth and that type of thing coming down
the street so
that that's another great energy to have
in the club I can't say like Joe
absolutely [__] picked the perfect
venue and crushed it it's unbelievable
so anyway
so that all happens that's Saturday
killer show Friday at College Station
um
which by the way Chris Layton drummer
for Stevie Ray Vaughan came out too with
one of his buddies I'm dropping names
all over the place I don't give a [__]
all right I'm still giddy
um
so that was Saturday
one of the greatest Days on the Road
I've ever had
and then Sunday we still get to go to
the race and we showed up and uh all the
races were great I would say the best
race of the day
was the Moto uh
uh Moto 3 race
um which I was so psyched because I
haven't seen one of those races since
they stopped having them on TV they do
have them on their website but like I
get so [__] busy that I only watch
the Moto GP so for those who don't watch
the the sport there's there's Moto 3
Moto 2 and then the top level and Moto 3
is like 17 18 year old future [__]
you know Stars of Moto GP on their way
up
and uh they all get the same engine they
almost look like those cafe racers
and it was just absolutely [__]
insane race
where
um this number five and I forget the
other guy that kept swapping the lead
and then the lead guy crashed
and he just sort of low-sided it
on the on the uh like turn 14 or 16 or
something like that somewhere over there
and uh the dude right behind him number
five had to slow down and in slowing
down he went from second and being on
the podium to be in like fifth or sixth
and there was only two laps to go and
dude this guy I I don't know who this
kid is but he raced angry man he [__]
just went all out past two guys in one
[__] turn I believe and worked his
way all the way back up to second place
again
um crowd was going crazy
and then the next one was Moto two
and uh I'm a Joe Roberts fan you know I
gotta root for the Americans here and
he's got the red white and blue bike and
he was in uh I think he was in 16th and
he got all the way up to Ninth at one
point and uh I think there was something
going on with the bike because he was
riding great uh but I got to watch him
he he ran great and uh that was another
amazing
um race and then the last one the Moto
GP one was crazy
because it was really windy like on
Saturday it was hot but uh on Saturday
it was really windy and like on the
first lap
like three guys like just [__] wiped
out
um
I don't know what was going on like they
said something about the tire pressure
in the front tire and the wind was just
taking these guys out and like I think
like nine Riders went down not getting
bumped or anything just going into a
turn and the bike just went out from
underneath him I think with the wind or
something like that I have no idea but
unlike the first
on the first lap like
um
that guy Fabio Gian
Gian Antonio whatever his name is riding
that light blue Ducati he he low sided
and then slid into his own teammate Alex
Marquez just took him right out I mean
they they could have been more than four
turns into the [__] race
and two million dollars of motorcycles
and an entire team were out I forget who
else wiped out I don't know if it was
Jack Miller or something like that there
was so many big names that went down of
course uh
uh is it pekko a pekka
uh Francesco
I don't know how to say his name he
[__] he was in first place in the
second race in a row he low-sighted and
didn't get any Goddamn point he did get
to 25 I think in the Sprint race but I'm
totally back into this sport I had a
great time Alex rinse ended up winning
it
and they asked me the night before they
go hey do you want to present the trophy
club soda called me up hey they want to
know if you want to present the trophy
and I'm like for what they're like the
mo the guy who wins the Moto GP like
they want me to do that doesn't have
like a hot chick does that they're like
they're asking you and I always say no
to that [__] I'm always like nah nah I'm
not gonna do that that's
uh I could barely ride a motorcycle
that's stupid I shouldn't do that that's
outside my wheelhouse but I was just
like
ah I give I'll do that I don't give a
[__] right so I show up
the end of the race they bring me down
there I'm standing behind the [__]
Podium and I'm watching
like these guys as they come in first
second and third place guy and their
team's going nuts and they're all
screaming and how psyched they are I've
always seen that on TV but to see it
live the energy is crazy on the other
side where I was sitting I saw them
bringing in all the bikes that wiped out
on this sad little golf cart that
that brought it in a trailer
so [__] funny man to see a bike that
can go 220 [__] miles an hour getting
brought in on a little golf cart towed
in
um
so I'm sitting back there and uh
I'm like I'm thinking really gonna have
me do this and then when I got back to
like no you just I I I only handed out I
didn't hand out one to any of the
writers I was the first guy
I gotta post the video it's [__]
hilarious I like I I I brought out the
trophy for the uh what is it the
builders whatever they call it um Honda
won that day so they they you know they
they won the builders Championship or
something at that thing so it's this
little Trophy and they go
uh the person announcing goes and to
present the builders trophy he goes
American comedian Bill Burr right and
there was like a golf clap right
and of course I couldn't just walk right
to the guy I had to walk all the way
past the other Riders and I was I just
felt like such a [__] right but I
was still also like geeking out that I
was there
and uh I [__]
handed the Honda guy shook his hand oh
and the Ducati guys are giving me a
shirt and they they were like you can't
wear that out there
so somebody gave me their sport coat to
wear out there so I don't know why
whatever
um and then I stood there and then the
guy that runs all of MotoGP
you know he handed out all the trophies
and uh
right as I was thinking like oh [__]
they're gonna spray each other with
champagne I don't I don't want to be a
part of this
the guy who handed out the trophies was
walking away
and and he just goes me he goes they're
going to spray champagne I go all right
thank you thank you for telling me that
because this isn't my sport coat and
then I I was able to get the [__] out of
there
um
yeah that was my weekend then I went
down and I I did the open mic at Joe's
club and I hung out with Rogan
and Tony and everybody and we just had a
[__] Dean we just had a [__] blast
I don't know why all of a sudden I just
felt guilty telling you guys all of this
[__]
I don't know why yeah
I probably should have left the trophy
part I think you guys were like all
right Bill we get it you had a good
[__] weekend you [__] you want to
hear about my weekend I was supposed to
have it off and then they [__] called
me in because Susie [__] cakes got the
mumps
and now I and I gotta [__] I gotta
deal with that [__] I got a cover for
you know I didn't have to
but they said you know we'd really
appreciate it
if you would come in sorry
this might be Catholic guilt I I
apologize I had a Make-a-Wish weekend
right and I'm not even sick
I am as healthy right now as you guys
are sick of hearing about my weekend
look at that 38 [__] minutes
I just talked about
um
anyway uh
Pekka Pekka beignet that's how you say
it
Jack Miller Brad Bender
oh nakagami was another guy he wiped out
um I think all of those guys wiped out
there's like a couple of teams that just
I don't know
it was Unreal I want to tell you too
this is the first time I went to Austin
and I realized why people moved there
you know what it is they visit Austin in
April
all right but you really need to go
there in the summertime okay that's when
you separate the men from the real
Texans
[Laughter]
you can handle 106 degrees but it's got
a you know it's got a great food
and a really cool Vibe and
you know
I get it
I never got it I spent you know what I
spent three days there I was like all
right I get this I get this
um I would still live outside the city
though
if that ever happens I'm gonna I'm gonna
[__] live in the middle
you know but then if you live in the
middle of nowhere then your neighbors
are scary
you know
they got like that think the way I do
you know you know people like don't like
when you don't think the way they do and
then they try to hurt you like
psycho liberals
think the way we think or we will and
you say what we say or we will end your
career
you know
and then you got psycho conservatives
you know think the way we think or we
will shoot you
um all right that's probably you know
that was cartoon versions of both sides
but it was it was it was fair right
i trash both
um anyway
okay so this is what I have coming up um
if you want to go to this live in person
the live MMP that I'm doing at the
legendary troubadour
um who've been so great to me and uh a
bunch of people went down there
and did shows for them during covid to
make sure they would be okay
because they've been so great to artists
for all of these [__] years and [__]
joke telling Comics like myself
um
people have been doing shows there and
they were able to survive so I'm
continuing to go down there because I
love that place
um
so many of the bands that I've grew up
listening to got their big break there
or did shows there and all of that [__]
so it's going to be at the Troubadour if
you are in Los Angeles area and you
would like to be in attendance for the
live Monday Morning podcast worldwide
stream event
happening April 23rd at noon
uh tickets will go on sale at the time
this podcast is published go to uh
troubadore.com right now limited tickets
are available there's like a hundred
I think tickets available and
um it's going to be a great time and uh
someday I gotta do a run of stand
updates there
you know I would love to do that
um
and by the way I am going to go back at
some point
if Rogan will have me and I will
headline that club
uh
hopefully sometime soon I'm trying to
like line it up
where it works out but I'm definitely
going to do it man God damn it that
place was beautiful all right let's do
some reads here everybody Simply Safe
Simply Safe uh who's playing to do hey
hey everybody who's planning to do some
spring cleaning this year
uh dust those hard to reach places clean
out that closet you know the one here's
my advice clean your house and then
protect every inch of it with Simply
Safe home security I recommend it to
everyone well except criminals I don't
care if you get ripped off uh Simply
Safe is designed with Cutting Edge
technology and backed by 24 7
Professional monitoring in an emergency
agents use fast protect technology only
from SimpliSafe to capture critical
evidence and verify the threat is real I
am the danger so you can get priority
police dispatch 24 7 Professional
monitoring service costs under one
dollar a day less than half the price of
traditional home security systems you
can lock and unlock your doors you can
access your cameras in arm and disarm
your system from anywhere [__] Buck
Rogers [__] man CNET name SimpliSafe
editor's choice for 2023 customize the
perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simplysafe.com go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
twenty percent off your order with
interactive monitoring that's
simplysafe.com there's no safe
like simply safe and I'm going to spell
it s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash Burr
All Right freeze pipe
this is not junkies smoking crack
in November freeze pipe is smoking
cannabis does doesn't have to hurt
all right
doesn't have to hurt Everybody Hurts
sometimes
so hold on you know angry that song used
to make me
because I didn't want to get in touch
with that part of me
when that song used to come on [__]
MTV
it hurts I feel like Oh shut the [__] up
[__] REM [__] and now I love the
band
not AC DC
you know
it takes a very special band
to sing about broads they're balls and
the devil for 50 straight years and it
never gets old
um All Right freeze pipe
sorry I'm in the 80s smoking cannabis
doesn't have to hurt upgrade to a freeze
pipe today and experience bigger
smoother clouds without the throat burn
chest pain or coughing attacks
freeze pipe makes a unique
line of freezable pipes
bubblers bongs and dag rip dab rigs
bubblers
bongs dab rigs wow
it's [__] weed smokers on I don't
know what half this [__] is that cool
Smoke by over 300 degrees every piece is
made you can take a bigger hit
you get all you can take a [__] Snoop
Dogg hit
without coughing and embarrassing
yourself with freeze pipe
every uh every piece is made out of
thick glass and smoke so smooth you'll
check if the bowl is even lit the secret
is freezable glycerin
oh Glycerine who is that band
bush
right the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers that come on every piece
uh pop one of these Chambers in the
freeze for one hour
and as smoke passes through it instantly
chilled it's instantly chilled
for a free for a pain-free and
refreshing experience think logic clouds
with zero chest and throat burn finally
no more coughing attacks no more water
chugging with everywhere okay we get it
elegant smoking blah blah blah it's
[__] fantastic smoke shop pipes
popless bongs and more uh you can shop
for these things at freespipe.com and
use the code burp Burr for 10 off your
entire order that's freeze pipe.com and
code Burr for 10 off your order today
and say goodbye to harsh smoke forever
oh look who it is everybody would you
look would you look who it is it's all
zip
grow up
um zip recruiter everybody
yes it's sip recruiter everybody
oh the one that started it all
no actually that was stamps.com but
whatever
they were there pretty early on weren't
they
[__] my notes
Jesus Christ
you know every time I go to do this [__]
the goddamn screen's shut off here we go
zip recruiter sip recruiter you know
whether you're starting a new business
or growing one if you want it to be
successful you need the most talented
people on your team that's where zip
recruiter comes in and right now you can
try it for free that's
it.com slash Burr why should you let
ZipRecruiter help you hire for your
business well that's because
recruiter
recruiters powerful matching technology
finds highly qualified candidates for a
wide range of roles let's zip
fill all your roles with the right
candidates four to five employers who
[__] with zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day you don't
have time to
jerk off at [__] Greenland
all right
you got a goddamn include a build
get me somebody with some their own
[__] mittens
see for yourself go to this exclusive
web address to try ZipRecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
again let me spell it z i p r e c r u i
t e r that's tough zip recruiter Rec
r-u-i-t-e-r that that's recruiter that
there's one there's one back in the day
that would have knocked me out of the
spelling bee
recruiter the weirdest recruiter I'd be
like recruiter r-u-c sit down Mr Burr
um that's ziprecruiter.com spell outbur
b-u-r-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh I love how I did that I just that's
my favorite part of the podcast that
little pause the smartest way to hire
bam nailed it
all right lazy young men
hey Bilbo Bergens love the show thank
you I figured out what's wrong with the
world oh did you figure it out oh thank
everybody put your brains on hold this
guy figured it out
I figured out what's wrong with the
world too many young men these days want
to sit around making YouTube videos
podcasts hey I'm offended or [__] on
only fans
it pains me to see a room full of
healthy fit young men talking [__] into
a microphone when they could be building
bridges and Roads what for some [__]
[__] with a top hat blowing out you
[__]
back [__] that [__]
build a goddamn Bridge they're already
built
no I'm kid I know what you mean uh I'm a
sewer worker in Australia and even
though the work is [__] pun intended I
earn enough to support my family easily
pay a mortgage put my kids through
private school and go skiing a couple
times a year
okay so you're gonna try to get a guy to
stop podcasting to go work on the town
[__]
I know about this argument buddy
um the lesson is hard and shitty work
pays well oh there you go a call to
young men to stop fantasizing about
being a [__] with a microphone and
get out there help with the labor
shortage get your hands a little [__]
dirty and put some hair on your chest as
for you Bill you're too old to swing
spanners I don't even know what that
means keep making us laugh with your
microphone mate um
yeah I I don't know that's that's a hard
sell if somebody's actually making money
podcasting
um
I will say blue collar jobs the people
you work with are great it's fun as hell
um but I I can't I can't act like I'm a
hard worker I I lasted like eight days
doing construction
and I still talk about it
I was a grunt I was like [__] I don't
know where the [__] I am in the packing
order of the world but this is I can't
I'm I'm
what am I gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
somehow become a
Finnish Carpenter or an electrician
I mean I could have done it through like
memorization but not through like having
the gift
so uh I kind of went away from that but
I I know what you mean I guess don't
worry they're gonna have robots soon
right
they already have they have robots on
the subway platform and uh
New York City now how long do you think
before somebody [__] kicks that thing
over the edge
in front of a train I mean that's gonna
happen at some point
they call it the snitchbot
uh all right Centris [__]
uh here we go again
you know why can't it just be a person
that you know tries to listen to both
sides before he makes a decision
[__] up
[__] man bun [__]
um Centrist I love how liberals just
they got a [__] word for everything
they're supposed to be liberal why are
they always name-calling I understand
the [__] conservative [__] you know
they like everything from the n-word to
uh whatever the [__] right
but like liberals they do Centrist
he's he's a Centrist
um oh god with your hairy pits all right
William words a lot
you know we've reached a point in
history where you get insulted for
wanting a society where nobody nobody
gets
everything
but everybody gets something
nobody gets everything oh nobody Hoards
all of it but everybody gets something
you get insulted for that uh the purity
test on either poll of the political
Spectrum are equally as intolerant
Mattingly maddeningly so
yeah that's why I I have somehow
you know maybe that's a good argument
for people to call you call you Centrist
it's like you ever think maybe a few
liberals weren't such [__] in [__]
intolerable [__] while calling
yourselves liberal I could [__]
you know listen to you a little more
you know
and I'm not into the conservative side
either Lloyd that's just like it just
should just be for white people
which really is what so much of their
[__] comes down to and then you have the
other people it's just like hey thinking
you know we gotta [__] you know
whatever the [__] they're talking about
you say use these words or you can I'm
gonna [__] comment yeah I don't even
know I don't even give a [__] I can't
even I can't make a [__] intelligent
argument for either side I'm just sick
of them
I'm sick of you can't even look at a
[__] pickup truck on Instagram
without somebody like politicizing it
you know hey snow Frank this is what a
real truck sounds like you [__] dick
sucking snowflake it's just like I
I can't just enjoy this F-150
you know oh I don't get me [__]
started and then liberals out here oh
fly over State it's like you're from
that state you douche I get it somebody
hung you by your underwear from the door
and now you can never go back there and
you think just because you moved that
you're somehow successful
all right
see I'm not a Centrist [__] I'm a a
separatist
um all right though I don't personally
subscribe to either of the major parties
there is one streak of libertarianism
that makes sense my rights end where
yours begin I like that
you know I don't wanna I don't want to
be the guy telling somebody
what the [__] they can and can't do but
I also don't want somebody doing
something
that you know
is [__] with my ability to be happy
you know we could we should just okay
hey I want to do this you want to do
that let's find a [__] Middle Ground
I don't understand what the problem with
that is anyways it says
e pluribus unum
I don't know what that means on lots of
USA USA stuff like our coins
uh oh it's supposed to go USA USA stuff
like our coins but Americans don't know
Latin
most people don't know Latin
people always [__] not America you know
what I mean you're just jealous about
movies and our blue jeans man
um it means out of many one
all right can you now tell me what that
means
out of many one
oh all of us make one
Jesus Christ how [__] annoying was
that whole [__] paragraph
most you guys you know Americans don't
know Latin here's the Latin phrase and
here's what it means in English and I'm
still not smarter
are more informed anyway being able to
consider both sides of an argument is
now a radical school of thought that
puts you in the crosshairs of the left
and the right which proves my point
oh gee what happened here we're just
listening to you make a point you didn't
prove your point someone who doesn't
agree with you then says you know what
you proved your point
did you just bestow that [__] Victory
on yourself
huh
you [__]
self
ribbon given [__]
sorry uh those that claim their side is
the tolerant one is completely full of
[__] that's true they're both completely
intolerant and the extremes
the extremes of both sides I don't see
why I should have to be at work between
a Bible
misappropriating Holy Roller and a
non-binary pansexual who identifies as a
ferret
um what gives either of them the right
to try and bend the world to their
distorted way of thinking just shut up
both of you and that's not because I'm
intolerant it's because I have other
[__] to deal with and you're putting it
in my front yard thank you
exactly just shut up I don't give a [__]
what you're doing just stop
you know these [__] dictators man
anyway maybe I need sensitivity
re-education by the way I'm still
laughing from the Forest Hill Stadium
show last August that was another fun
one yeah I kind of agree with that and I
guess that makes you like a Centrist
like
you know I I listen to people
you know try to listen to what they're
saying I get it you're into your guns
I don't want to take them from you
unless you're a [__] lunatic and okay
you identify as whatever the [__] you
all right
I'll do my best to use the right pronoun
but you know I have a life too that I
have to get to and if I say the wrong
pronoun I don't want to listen to you
[__] flipping out about it
you know
I gotta keep my head on a swivel Kick a
Ginger days coming up or did it go by I
don't know
some of the best things about shaving my
head
my shins thank my head every day
once a year
um
anyway
yeah I think most I gotta be honest with
you I think most conservative people and
most liberal people are uh
I think most of us are are sort of the
way you describe it was like all right
okay I get it you know everybody [__]
relax
we stop yelling at each other it's so
dumb
um I know Bill you say this every
episode I know I know sorry anyway
naming my kid Robinson
all right dear Mr Billy tits
I have I am contemplating having a kid
soon and thinking that naming it
Robinson would be cool
I think it would be it would work as a
boy or a girl name it is a cool name
because of Jackie Robinson and Robinson
canoe
it also has lots of good nicknames first
different stages of life if it's a boy
his nickname could be Robbie Rob Bob
Bobby Etc
uh lots of cool sounding nicknames so he
will probably have lots of friends right
um depends if he's good at sports or not
um
yeah because if you have an
uncoordinated boy and he's named after
Robinson Canoa Jackie Robinson then I
don't know
who knows if it were a girl she could go
by Robin so what do you think Billy red
nuts is Robinson a good name from my
first kid yeah you know if you like it
I'm not good at that [__] I don't have
to know what your last name is
you know it's not Caruso is it
um
I would I think it's more of a boy name
you know
yeah I would think that I I'm you know
I'll be honest with you I'm not good at
that [__]
my wife is good at that [__] and but
then once she picks the name and I hear
it I'm like that's a [__] good name
that is a good name
um
yeah I suck at that [__] I'm not good at
like uh this all of that type of stuff I
suck at
you know name and [__] like they always
go like you got to come up with a name
for your tour and I'm just like I I
bald cut tells jokes we can't put that
on a poster I I don't what what do you
want to call it
Bill Burr Pays His mortgage
I can't even say mortgage Paces mortgage
how about that can we call it that
uh
nah something that's got a little flow
um not good at that I'm not good at uh
decorating a room
or a man cave or any of that [__] I'm
just not I whatever that is
I'm not good at that so uh don't ask me
about kid names I don't I don't want to
do that I agonize over that [__] because
I'm just like what is the name that I
can give them that will give them the
easiest life I just don't want to have
somebody
some of these [__] names that some
people have given their kids
Jesus Christ
and I don't want to say the names
because they're the names of actual
people they don't need the [__]
headache but good Lord
we get it you're interesting oh my God
what an interesting [__] name
this is my son Fawcett
um ultimate date fumble
what's up you miserable add [__]
laughs
I want to argue that but I can't
um for some reason having you yell in my
ear twice a week has tricked my brain
into trusting you so I'd like to tell
you about one of my most embarrassing
moments
I asked out this hot lady
from my class
look at you good for you and we were
having a nice time on our first date we
were driving around and ended up at this
playground near our Apartments it had
been raining all day so everything was
nice and wet we were walking towards the
fence and in a moment of douchebaggery I
asked her if she could hop a fence she
said yes and I then attempted oh no
and I then attempted to clear this wet
fence in one smooth motion to
impress the sexy little broad I
completely wiped out ah
oh my God
I immediately pictured like Jim Carrey
and Dumb and Dumber you know making some
confident face that he just [__]
because I ended up on my ass with my arm
and hand completely scraped up in
bleeding profusely
on the other hand she jumped over it
like a normal human being and got over
it with no trouble uh
does the humiliation ever end I laughed
it off as best I could but lost all my
mojo after that kind of hard to make a
move when you're covered in blood we
never went out again and of course she
was in my lab group the next semester so
I had to work closely with her for
months do you have any embarrassing date
stories with all due respect go [__]
yourself
um
yeah yeah of course I do
of course I do they're too embarrassing
to even even where do I even begin
embarrassing date stories I mean
everything
um
the one that comes to my mind I I just
don't want to tell
It's really because I just don't want to
embarrass
you know I mean like you can tell your
story right and nobody knows who you are
or who the [__] person I don't want
to tell my story out of like
you know uh consideration for the other
[__] person all right I never hopped
a fence
but I definitely
um
all right I can tell I think I can tell
this one because I didn't date this
person for too long I remember one time
I [__]
I was dating this chick right
or whatever we were doing I thought we
were just banging she thought it was a
relationship so
um that was something I learned too if
you're just banging a chick you can't
bang them more than once in a month you
gotta go six six weeks
and then really not talk to them
and then not there'll be no confusion or
you could just tell him
that's what it is
they never tell guys that when we're
young just just tell them what the [__]
you want right right now there's a bunch
of women going yes well that works both
ways so don't get all [__] excited
all right you guys don't exactly
communicate too with your [__]
riddles
um of body language or whatever the [__]
we're supposed to be picking up um
all right here's one for you this is
just embarrassing in general so
um I grew up in a overly testosterone
Neighborhood Family
I mean I think even all the dogs in my
neighborhood were were male
it was just like a [__] sausage fest
so I didn't know and all I played was
[__] Sports
and I didn't know [__]
about women
you know I didn't know what they liked
what they went to I had no [__] clue
so I go out to the world right
I was a late bloomer and I was an
introverted psycho right so I get I
think this was my
second girlfriend
second or third I can't remember what
all I know was her [__] birthday was
coming up
and I was like Jesus Christ what the
[__] do I don't even I don't I have no
idea
what to get a woman for a gift I had no
idea and I was on the road
I just started doing comedy
and I went into a mall to try and find
her something
I think I told this story before
I don't know why this is so [__] a
better you know what I got her I you
know like you know like those polo style
shirts
that like you know
people were in the 80s
you know sort of the date rapist [__]
shirt like the alligator ones the izods
like the polo I bought her three of
those
[Music]
and I wrapped them up nicely and I I
gave her a card and she was all excited
I said hey happy birthday I got you
something I remember I was I was in a
bedroom she had this apartment
and uh
I was so [__] nervous I was just
going oh my God please please like let
her like this and she
opened it up and she took the first one
out and she held it up and she had a
puzzled look on her face
and then she
took the next one out and then she just
went like
what is what is this what what
and then she took the third one realized
that that's all it was and she got mad
she goes why would you buy me this this
is like stupid and she just started go
she started
like
not yelling but loud talking
about how [__] awful the gift was
and I didn't know what to do I literally
sat down on the bed and was like looking
down at the floor is she like sort of
berated me
I mean looking back she was right I was
a [__] idiot
but uh I also got you something for your
birthday you [__] [__] so
I finally regained my footing after
about 90 seconds of getting balled out
as we used to call it getting yelled at
dude I got [__] balled out in second
period teacher's a douche
um
anyway she [__] yells at me for uh I
don't know like 90 sec I don't know how
long it was it was [__] humiliating
and then I just got mad surprise
surprise I was just like
I was like all right so you don't you
know you don't [__] like it what is
you give you a [__] birthday you're
yelling at me and then she kind of
realized
she was like no no I'm sorry and I was
like ah go fat [__] you right and I just
said that
not because I wasn't accepting her
apology it was because I was so [__]
embarrassed I just wanted to get out of
there
you know like you ever see a baseball
manner just sometimes just absolutely
flip out about this littlest thing it
was just like did he really do that to
get his team going or did he just not
feel like managing today like Jesus
Christ 162 [__] games a year
oh my God yeah that wasn't a strike I'll
fire you fat [__] [__] you
[__] yeah hit the showers all right
thanks
how was the game honey oh great I only
had to do three innings
why what happened ah nothing
I just got sick of listening to people
spitting all right that's the podcast
everybody thank you so much for
listening uh thank you to Joe Rogan for
uh building that comedy club investing
his own money in it and just making the
what this
absolute
Palace for comedians to work out in and
have open mics thank you to everybody
Ducati MotoGP thank you for Dean Del Rey
for from
introducing me to those people I just
had the greatest weekend and of course
to the great club soda Kelly just a
[__] awesome weekend we had a great
time thank you everybody in Austin
people in College Station all of that
and thanks to you guys it works for all
of us the United Way all right go [__]
yourselves and I will check in on you on
a Thursday